there's something really interesting
about romantic infatuation the kind of
Romeo and Juliet romantic passion you
know aka love of the adolescent that we
celebrate in song and in literature that
we are often told later by psychologists
is a sort of legalized form of insanity
in that when people fall into each other
when they fall into that heated fire in
the valley that infatuation for the
other that mutual engendering of godhood
results in a kind of narrowing of focus
right we are told that biochemically no
different than doing lots and lots of
cocaine when we come
but addicted to the other person and we
use that as a means to dismiss the
authenticity of that feeling as a way of
somehow saying it is not worthy of our
attention because it's a kind of
pathology and I was reading this amazing
article on brain pickings that was
saying the strangest most paradoxical
thing is that there is nothing near
about being inflamed by passion
infatuation as much as it may drive us
mad because is a singularly potent and
utterly addictive drug with the capacity
to narrow our focus so spectacularly as
to reduce the entirety of the world to
the object of our desires so think about
that again infatuation narrows our focus
so much than the rest of the world
dissipates and goes dim the entirety of
the cosmos becomes this one person right
that's a lot of pressure no relationship
compare the burden of godhood and yet is
there anything more delicious than
succumbing into those moments of grace
where you see the universe in the iris
of your lover's eye in other words in
the madness and the intoxication of
romantic passion we may be lying to
ourselves we may be making art out of
our relationship but art is the lie that
reveals the truth and so I always say my
lover's bhai to me but lie to me well
make me metabolize belief make me
suspend disbelief wait to be believed
ultimately love is a religious problem
it's an act of faith it's an act of
surrender
I'm care we're lying to ourselves we are
creating a cosmology of two we are
dirtying each other into gods
outside of time commingling together
stepping off that people were that's
caring everyone else toward dead
and so that's what we do we arrest time
time through a mutual reinforcing
delusion that becomes a theater of the
real we enter an epistemic plane
together a world of two shaped like a
heart
so I don't care if love is madness I
still love it
you